- [Mark] Okay, Norman.
- Hey, what's going on?
- [Mark] Welcome back.
- Yes sir, good to be back.
- [Mark] So day after Thanksgiving,
what's going on with you now?
- Oh, well part-time workers
were laid off at the job.
Usually that would be
something that would be
a huge trigger for me.
I would get in that mind frame
always of I'll show them.
- [Mark] So you got, you got laid off.
- Yes, yes, I got laid off
along with about 12 others.
We were all part-time workers.
And you know, I understand
the onus of part-time.
That's exactly what it
is, part-time, you know.
We did a lot of work,
we did some overtime,
but unfortunately, I mean this is
what they decided due to COVID.
It's not nothing that,
on me, so that's good.
But usually I would
have that frame of mind
with I'll show them and I go and fuck up.
You know, and I've looked
back at those things
and I'm like, okay, I didn't do that.
Then I said, why didn't I do it?
Well, I didn't want to.
And then faced with
what I would call a debacle.
I stood up and I said, okay,
let's go back to the drawing board.
Go back and put your
resume back out there.
- [Mark] Good for you.
- And I have a interview Monday.
- [Mark] That's great.
You know, I mean,
this is when life shows up.
I mean, you know, just because you
move away from something
that was bad for you
doesn't mean that negative
things won't happen.
You know, of course it's negative.
You know, I loved the job.
It was, it was a nice little commute.
It was a wonderful job.
You know, I was a floor leader,
but you know unfortunately this is life,
you know and this is what happens.
So, you know, when life shows up
for me, God better show up and show out.
Or I'm going to show up
and I'm going to show out
and I'm going to go out.
You know, but I don't
do those things anymore.
I do it one day at a time.
Like I was telling my buddy the other day,
I don't even count my days.
You know, when I wake up in the morning,
I go through my prayer meditation.
I ask God what he wants me to do today.
And I leave it alone.
You know, as things
come, I deal with them.
The holidays are usually something
that kind of rattles me.
Didn't rattle me this year
because I really kind of got
the gist of thanksgiving.
You know, thanks for God allowing me
to be in His presence
and give me my life back.
I'm thankful to the company for hiring me,
at least giving me a chance.
You know, you never
know who seen this video
and said, oh hell no, we're
not going to hire him.
He's a crack addict.
You know, he's one check Norman,
he always goes out, you know?
Well I just dispelled that damn rumor.
You know, I got a few checks,
and didn't go nowhere.
Took care of some bills, took
care of some past due stuff,
you know, don't have the money
that I would want to have, but it's okay.
You know, I'm breathing.
I have something to eat.
You know, it's a little tough right now,
but it's going to be okay.
It's going to be okay.
When you really look at things
in a frame of mind that it is what it is.
It's like that power
of choice and control.
I didn't have any power
over what they did.
I really didn't have a choice
and I had no control of the situation,
but I did have control
over what I would do.
I did have a semblance of
control of my thinking.
Usually the first thought is pow.
But it wasn't.
And I thank God for that
because I said, okay,
And I thought on the bus on the way home,
I got to the house, I told my buddy,
he was very encourage-able,
as he always has been,
and as he always will be.
He said, okay, well
you've never had a problem
getting a job.
You've had a problem keeping 'em.
And guess what, this one was not on you.
You didn't do anything to leave the job.
You didn't do anything
to have the managers
or anybody else saying
okay what's wrong with him
or anything like that.
It's just a normal
occurrence in everyday life.
And you handled it.
You know, you gotta have that wherewithal.
- [Mark] how you handle
these setbacks, like this
dictates so much of--
- Right.
You know, it's just like, of
course I'm bummed out about it.
You know because it was
a chance to go further.
But I still have a chance to go further.
As long as I have a chance,
you take chances in life every day.
Somebody had walked up to me one time
and asked me did I want to gamble?
I said, no, I'm already gambling.
They said what do you mean?
You're standing here talking to me.
I gamble on life.
Every time I took a hit of crack cocaine
I was gambling with my life.
Every time I did something
that I wasn't supposed to do
I was gambling with my life.
Especially taking something
from somebody else
or something like that.
You know, man, it is what it is.
I'm gonna keep going.
The humility that I'm
gaining from the experience
of having a setback and not
going back is different.
You know, I was thinking
this morning, I'm like,
damn, man, you still going.
They said, okay, bye-bye,
but you didn't say bye-bye.
because I usually end the
book, this is the last chapter.
And it's like four or five pages.
There's no going on, there's
no trying to go to school
and get a book report because
there is no book report.
It's the same news all the
time, well, Norman's gone.
I remember my son told me
one time he said he called me
and he couldn't get ahold of me.
He say, well, my dad's gone
and I don't want him to say that anymore.
You know he's a good kid.
He's doing what he's supposed to do.
He has a wonderful little
son, my little grandson.
And he's doing what he's supposed to do.
My middle daughter is in Las Vegas
with my grandkids,
really miss my grandkids
especially my granddaughters.
Cause they, they like to
jump on me all the time
and I'd like to pick them up,
throw them on the couch
and they keep coming back.
You know, I kind of dig that
kind of stuff, I'm a big kid.
My oldest daughter is
doing extremely well.
She's married, she lives in
Virginia and she's happy.
And that's what really pushes me to
those moments of blissfulness.
You know, when I can just sit back
recollect, just having a good day.
And even sometimes when I would come home
because I worked the night shift
and I'd come home about
7:15 watching the news
I'll eat something and I'll
sit back and I'll think,
you know, hey, how did your day go?
Do you, did you keep something to yourself
which you should have
shared with somebody else?
What could you do better for the next day?
And that's how I look at it.
You know, I don't have any,
it's not so much that getting
high is not an option anymore
because you always have
choices and options.
It's just not a risk
that I'm willing to take.
To have all of these people who
give me so much encouragement, you know
I still go in there and I'll
read them over and over again.
And most importantly, the naysayers.
You boost me, so keep
those bad comments coming.
Like LeBron says, I want my damn respect
but respect is earned and I
don't owe anyone, anything.
And you guys out there that are listening
you don't owe me anything.
But to the naysayers,
keep the comments coming,
cause they really boost me.
It's like, I'm a space X,
rocket, and I'm always going up.
You know, I'm even gonna
stop commenting back
because I don't need to.
My action will speak so loud
you can't hear shit I'm saying.
That's how I'm looking at it.
- [Mark] You seem a much
more grounded this time
than any other time I've seen.
- Yeah. I mean, you know,
well the seed is planted
and it's being watered.
Now, it's just not going to sprout up
and turn into a Sequoia tree overnight.
I mean, this is an ongoing process.
You're looking at a person who's used
for 30 something years.
Was an active user at a job.
Nobody knew what the hell I was doing.
It's just, the choice is up to me.
You know, I faced those times,
actually to tell you the truth,
and I don't want to sound
arrogant or egotistical,
I welcome the times that will come
where I'm faced with a decision.
Because usually I only had one decision
now, not so much do I have a decision,
I have choices I can make.
I can choose to go the wrong way.
I can choose to go the right way,
I can keep going forward.
Or I could choose to go backwards.
And the choice is up to me.
So we just keep going, we
take it one day at a time.
We don't look further.
I'm prepared for the interview Monday
even though it's Friday.
The game face will be on Sunday.
The Mamba Mentality will be there Monday.
I don't know if anybody ever
really listened to Kobe Bryant.
But for me and going through
what I've been going through
he's helped me tremendously
in what he said about himself.
And how he had instituted wherewithal
because he said he wanted to be the best.
So he worked at it.
So if I want to be better,
I need to work at it.
Day, after day, after day,
every day is not going to be
like it is outside
sunny, clear blue skies.
There gonna be some clouds.
There gonna be some rain.
There's gonna be some thunderstorms.
Am I going to carry that umbrella
of wherewithal with me at all times.
That is the key question right now.
Of course, because
that's what I want to do.
I don't owe my kids anything.
But what I want them to know
is that I'm going to do the
best that I possibly can
to not so much, see any,
any male could be called daddy
but it takes a man to be a father.
I have to relearn how to be a father
because I never had a father.
So I'm relearning that.
I'm really learning how to handle setbacks
and negative situations
in a conducive manner
rather than running.
I mean these 56 year old legs,
they still got some pump in them,
but I'm tired, tired of running.
And we're just going to
take it a day at a time.
It's all we can do, you know,
it's either this or that.
Choice is mine.
- [Mark] Excellent, you're doing it, man.
I can tell.
- I'm just going to keep going.
- [Mark] Yeah, you don't even seem like
(laughing)
- He looks at me like, man, you know,
you don't really look like Norman no more.
- No you don't.
- What the fuck you mean
I don't look like Norman?
- [Mark] Not the Norman that we've known.
- He said because you was a
bony motherfucker, that's why.
I was like, well, you know, hey, you know?
Cause I wanted to cut
my hair, but you know
didn't have the money to do it.
And you know, because I had
to take care of some things
but I'm glad that,
see the records of your past will come up
a lot, especially when you get sober.
Because you've done some things
under the auspices of getting high.
And then when you get
sober, here they come.
I.e. bills, collectors, things like that.
I have some negative
things on my credit report.
I took care of them.
I had all kind of shit that was,
that had to be taken care of.
And I didn't mind not
having a dime in my pocket
because I know I took care of it.
Okay. That's down, so
we go and we mark that.
What else do we have to take care of?
We have to take care of this.
We've marked that and
you just keep on marking.
The day will come where
it'll be somewhat settled
because I don't ever think anything
in life is going to be just settled.
Life to me is a chess match.
And the ultimate chess master rules me.
So He makes the moves.
See when I make the moves it's checkmate.
Now I can become empowered to
make the moves by the power
but it's not time yet.
You know, it's not like
I'm treading on thin ice
or anything like that, but it's too early.
You know, I've been in
this game a long time
and I understand it.
My disease is cunning
and baffling and powerful
as they say in the rooms
of anonymous fellowships.
And it may not have
come after me this time.
But it's not like I'm suffering
from impending doom either
but I know what's coming.
So I'm asking God to keep
staking that fortress around me
just keep staking, keep staking.
And He steaks it by my actions.
The more I seek Him,
the more He does for me.
the less I seek Him, the more He allows me
to be on my free will and do
what the hell I want to do.
He'll always take care of me,
but He's gonna allow me
to do what I want to do.
Because see if there's a pipe
in my heart, I'm gonna smoke.
They say, God gives you
what's in your heart.
You know, but there's
not a pipe in my heart.
He knew that they were
going to lay me off.
He knew I was going to need another job.
So He blessed me with an interview.
We're going to keep the Mamba Mentality.
Kobe Bryant had a lot of
wherewithal, an extreme amount.
He was much more than basketball for me.
Thank you Kobe,
for telling me some of the
things that you you've told me.
So I can see what I need to see.
And I'm glad I can see,
got a new pair of glasses.
Isn't that something?
- [Mark] All right Norman.
Good luck on Monday.
- Thank you, sir.
- All right, man.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Yeah. Kobe was the best.
- Yeah, If you don't, I don't give a Fuck
about Jordan going 6 and O,
if you don't put him in
the gold conversation
to me the greatest of all time is Kareem,
because nobody's done What he did.
You go from high school,
winning championships
college, winning championships
pros, winning championships.
Nobody's ever done that
all the way, like he did.
Lansing Eastern, he won one,
he won an NBA title
and Michigan state won their first one.
But we're talking about a guy who won
three straight in high school,
three straight in college,
wins it with the Bucks and
then wins five with the Lakers.
So that's six titles.
19 all-star appearances, eight MVP awards.
And an unstoppable shot.
If he's number one, if Kareem,
I'm putting him number one,
Kobe's number two.
- [Mark] They're all great.
- Yeah
- Kobe, LeBron,
- They had their own, they had their own
panache, about themselves, you know,
but he, I think that game in Utah
where he missed those air balls
they say he went back, he said it,
he said, he went back in that gym.
He shot 3000 shots a day.
That night, 3000.
So um, yeah, I cried like a baby,
when I heard about that.
Cause I've met him once
at the Staple Center
Larry Adamson, the president
of Midnight Mission.
He had a sky box and we
went down to the tunnel
and I got to meet him and he was cool guy.
He said, hey how'd you guys like the game?
He was like, oh, okay,
so what's your name man?
I said, Norman, he said Kobe.
All right, his little
daughters right there.
Tall, that motherfucker,
he's like six, six and a half, lanky dude.
Very, very cordial young
man, but he was needed.
And when you needed, you can't say,
okay no, I'm going to wait.
When the alarm clock
goes off, you gotta go.
You gotta go.
- [Mark] We were lucky to
be alive when he was alive.
- Yes sir, yes sir, yes sir.